hey folks welcome to a dark horse short
I am sitting this morning in person with
Nick Gibson who is a friend of mine he
started out in my Orbit as a participant
in the evolution discussion that I hold
monthly he has then started
participating in the Coalition of the
reasonable discussion and uh anyway
we've become friends um I thought it
would be a good idea for us to talk a
little bit about your trajectory over
the course of Co and I don't just mean
your trajectory physically but your
trajectory also in terms of your
understanding of uh various things I
think it will become obvious why we're
having that discussion uh when you tell
us what your journey has been like but
in any case Nick welcome to Darkhorse
thanks for having me so um tell us where
you were in early Co first of all I
should say if you are detecting a uh
somewhat thick accent that is because
Nick is actually from Canada which is
technically in North America but yeah
yeah barely bar yeah barely I mean it's
a very far foreign land it is it is uh
quite chilly in the winter but um in any
case the grass is not so green on the
other side of the border so it seems I
didn't even know that you had grass on
the other side of the the point but um
in any case uh tell us uh
roughly how Co was going for you in the
early days what you thought was going on
um and and how that changed over time
yeah I think like a lot of people I
didn't take it very seriously at the
beginning so if we think sort of
February 2020 I can distinctly recall
going into my office at work and you
know chumming with some colleagues and
just saying like oh it's fine just wash
your hands a little bit more and you
know get more sleep or whatever which
ironically may have been actually the
the right advice in the long long term
anyways but I had no sense of the what
would happen approximately a month from
then um as we got to the lockdowns in in
Canada much like uh most place in the
world in the United States I you know
took it all in just like every other
kind of Norm me out there I I wasn't as
scared of the virus personally I was
more concerned around it was going to
affect people around me per se so even
then implicitly I didn't feel that level
of fear but I definitely felt the the
heaviness of what was going on and all
the all the policy implications that um
that came out of it so yeah pretty
pretty standard standard middle of the
bell curve kind of reaction say and um
it's sometimes hard for me at least to
go back and reconstruct what was
understood when yeah but it seems to me
that even very early in the pandemic as
we were still wrestling with how hard we
were going to be hit here in in North
America it became clear pretty early
that it wasn't hitting healthy young
people especially hard right and at the
time you know before covid and and
during early Co you were uh highly
athletic healthy you didn't have chronic
health issues
um okay so you like many of us would
have looked at it and thought that's
worrying frightening but less so for me
because I don't have the conditions that
would make me especially vulnerable
given what we're seeing yeah exactly I
mean there's a little bit of you don't
know what you don't know and the
information landscape to say the least
was was pretty messy at the time but I'd
say my anxiety or nervousness or
whatever was more so related to the
broader broadly what was going on
relative to uh as opposed to the disease
itself the infection itself all right
and uh so how did things
develop yeah I'd say over time I slowly
but surely started to think things were
a little weird put it that way I'd say
by May June as things started to ease
off in the first kind of wave of things
I started feel comfortable with even
just seeing my family cuz you know my
parents are old but they're they're
older and certainly in a real sense Co
would affect folks who are above 60
above 70 more so than than the rest of
the population so I it's a little more
careful that way but by may I started
visiting them with no you know out of
the ordinary um
precautions and uh as the summer went on
cases went down uh but the fall came and
much like most places and and the well
all places get the fall in some way as
we know but in the the case of Co when
the fall rolled around uh I as you
mentioned I played different sports I
was playing in a softball league that
that fall and Ontario where I'm from
decided that uh they're going to do
another lockdown they're going to shut
down outdoor
softball and I was just perplexed I
think that was the first turning point
of a few uh during the course of the
this era well at that time we did not
know that the virus was not transmitted
by uh
rapidly moving spherical objects that uh
that's right yeah yeah it's it's
particularly bad on uh leather leather
things that you put on one hand right
the stitching also the hides on the
stitching get stuck in there you know
yeah well I guess of all of the insanity
that we went through the idea of
preventing people from being in outdoor
spaces doing healthy activities to me
strikes me as a near the top because any
hour that you spent doing that actually
was an hour that you were safe from
Contracting the Disease by virtue of the
fact that it just simply didn't transmit
that way which became clear fairly early
on yeah I I even add to that just in my
mind it was just so absurd on at least
two or three levels right I would kind
of
get at that point I don't agree with it
now but at that point I would have been
much more sympathetic to the idea of
indoor sports being closed down sure
even now at this point I don't even
think that's relatively the a case that
would make but I would been more
sympathetic to it but it was just such a
sweeping
over-the-top
ridiculous you know approach and um it
only kind of got worse in there it got
worse so um maybe the way to think about
this is we were on Parallel trajectories
I don't know at which point you uh
started paying attention to what we were
thinking about Co but the for us
initially we believed that um measures
that were being taken were sensible even
if we didn't know that they were working
you know a short lockdown I'm
embarrassed to say now but a short
lockdown uh seemed sensible enough I
think there's no way at the point that
we began locking down that there was any
controlling of the virus but at the time
it seemed reasonable masks seemed like
something um that was comparatively
lowcost and then of course these things
got taken over and they became uh
symbols of compliance and and uh it made
a lot of us rethink our initial position
but our first sponsor for this episode
is Paleo Valley paleo Valley makes a
huge range of products from supplements
like fish row and organ complex
grass-fed bone broth protein and
superfood bars everything we've tried
from them has been terrific including
their golden milk made with loads of
turmeric but we're going to talk today
about beef sticks the beef in these
delicious snacks comes from small
American-owned Farms that practice
rotational grazing paleo Valley's beef
sticks are 100% % grass-fed and finished
entirely organic and naturally fermented
100% grass-fed beef is more nutritious
than grain-fed beef in many ways
including that it contains more calcium
magnesium potassium zinc phosphorus
betacarotene and iron it's also utterly
delicious if you thinking that paleo
Valley's beef sticks are like Slim Jims
you're wrong for one thing unlike Slim
Jims paleo Val's beef sticks contain no
mechanically separated chicken parts for
another paleo Valley's beef sticks are
actually good for you ingredients hiding
in most beef sticks and jerky include
MSG hormones hydrogenated oils and
brominated vegetable oil which if you're
wondering what that is was first
patented as a flame retardant and now
it's in a lot of food not if you buy
paleo valy though furthermore unlike
other meat snacks paleo valy uses
natural fermentation to preserve its
beef sticks this gives the beef sticks a
long shelf life without the use of
harmful acids and chemicals and with the
added benefit of contributing to a
healthy gut paleo Valley beef sticks are
also keto friendly and make a great
protein Rich snack to grab when you're
on the go like running out the door for
a meeting podcast or going on a bike
ride paleo Valley doesn't cut Corners
they Source the highest quality
ingredients and are passionate not only
about human health but about
environmental restoration and Animal
Welfare as well and their family owned
try paleo Valley's beef sticks today
you'll be so glad you did head over to
paleo Valley that's p a l e o v a l l
y.com Darkhorse for 15% off your first
order our second sponsor for this
episode is Vivo barefoot shoes made for
feet Vivo was one of our very first
sponsors and they remain one of our
favorites everyone should try these
shoes most shoes are made for someone's
idea of feet but not Vios Vios are made
by people with feet who know how to use
them and word is spreading people have
have approached us because of the vios
we are wearing saying they've heard
they're great and wanting to know if
they really are well yes they are these
shoes are every bit as good as you've
heard these shoes are Beyond comfortable
the tactile feedback from the surfaces
you're walking on is amazing and they
cause no pain at all because there there
are no pressure points forcing your feet
into odd positions they're just
fantastic our feet are the products of
millions of years of evolution humans EV
evolve to walk move and run Barefoot
modern shoes that are overly cushioned
and strangely shaped have negatively
impacted foot function and are
contributing to a Health crisis people
move less than they might in part
because their shoes make their feet hurt
enter Vivo Barefoot Vivo barefoot shoes
are designed wide to provide natural
stability thin to enable you to feel
more and flexible to help you build your
natural strength from the ground up foot
strength increases by 60% in a matter of
months just by walking around in them
Vivo Barefoot has a great range of
Footwear for kids and adults for every
activity from hiking to training and
everyday wear they're also a certified
borp that is pioneering regenerative
business principles and their Footwear
is produced using sustainably sourced
natural and recycled materials with the
aim to protect the natural world so you
can run wild upon it go to viob
barfoot.co.nz v o b a r
f.com and use the code Darkhorse 15 at
checkout how did your so you were
somewhat skeptical of some of the
provisions but basically on board with
the
mainstream understanding for some time
and then there's a point at which that's
no longer true what happened to you yeah
actually I'll add some more context to
make that even more color I think I've
said this to you but I had the reaction
uh early on I don't remember exactly
when you started talking about lab leak
but I had the reaction of oh no Brett's
going down that
route uh and I I didn't you know I knew
you enough even at that point that I I
didn't completely write you off um
obviously I'm here so that didn't fully
happen but I was a little like oh no why
is he doing this why is he going down
there um because I was imbuing and
consuming the overall kind of Sho shoo
of that narrative right right um so just
for folks listening I think that just
adds even more color to the the
transition ended up happening so I'd say
going into 2021 uh folks were excited
more generally around the vaccine being
available and um
I I was generally happy you know
November when was announced that oh this
High efficacy and all the numbers it's
like oh okay look great such high e
that's right that's right
yeah uh you know I should know this as
someone who works with numbers in my day
job that um numbers can be played with
pretty easily nonetheless uh as that
went on I still kind of at first there
was the first wave of we don't have
enough we're going to triage who's going
to get it right there were a lot of
problems with that but in general I was
like yeah I don't need it I'm working
first of all you know my health my age
and I was working from home I was the
last person that needed to get one um
you know right away so I'm like okay I
won't even think about it right but then
in April May came around and by that
time unambiguously everyone who wanted
to get it could could get it and that
was the time where I'm starting to think
like I don't know about this especially
because cases were going down but I
still in my head thought okay I'm
probably still going to get at some
point but I just I wasn't prioritising
it um and as I heard more from you and
from others I was getting
more
concerned that it wasn't as advertised
to put it lightly um but I was talking
to some folks in the last day or so and
I don't exactly know what happened um to
say the least but I think eventually I
got to a point
where there was enough social
pressure that I felt like I need to you
know support others cuz as as I said
wasn't especially at that point wasn't
particularly concerned about the virus I
mean no one likes getting sick right
it's it's it sucks for a few days kind
of thing but um I did it my sister was
having a wedding about a month after I
ended up getting it in August of
2021 um and so the intention was to get
the first one give it you know three to
four weeks and I could get the second
one and it was well before her wedding
um which one did you get uh the madna
madna yeah yeah so
um that was just what was available at
the time and um yeah that was that ended
up being quite a turning point uh
because at first I was so relieved that
I'm like okay this decision is now
behind me right I've done it it's okay
we're good I expected that that night
was going to be a little messy most
people knew that there was a or at least
your setup to understand that the
symptoms that you get that night are you
know going to be a little rough you
might have a bad sleep generally
speaking I didn't have as good as sleep
normally would but it was fine it was
until the the days later that things
started to change
how yeah um one of those uh as I joked
with other people one of those lucky
lottery winners that um turns out this
is a pretty high odds Lottery but um
lucky lottery winners that had an injury
from the from the vaccine um you know it
was I'll put it this way I it sucked in
many ways and you know we might get more
into it as we go through this but
um I was quite fortunate relative to
other people and and that's a
perspective I I try to keep in my mind
even though um it would be difficult any
given day to do so but yeah I had any
very eclectic mix of symptoms so the
first bit was this sort of unbearable
fatigue so you mentioned I'm pretty
active so during the course of the day I
will go to the gym kind of at that time
was going in the afternoon so I'd go
midday if work was well you know going
well didn't have any other things I'd go
to the gym and then just pick up work
afterwards there was one day
about three no about four days later I
started noticing just like subtle
symptoms of fatigue and even just like
tightness and upper chest but then I
started like oh maybe this is my workout
right so I eased up a little bit and
then six or seven days in I came home
from work I was going to work I already
felt a little tired during the workout I
was like oh man I really can't push
today this is weird maybe I just need to
take it easy and on the way back I was
so tired that I needed to message one of
my colleagues and say I'm sorry I I'm
done for the rest of the day I just need
to I need to nap like and I've never had
that urge before it was just so
overwhelming and so I'm like okay maybe
I'm burning myself out it didn't make
sense because it was the middle of
summer and you know stress levels were
actually relatively speaking the
pandemic were pretty
um manageable at that point but um took
some time off from the gym and uh was
actually planning to go on a trip out to
uh western Canada for a conference I was
going to on the Friday morning and uh
woke up that morning with what I thought
was well for onten of purposes thought
it might have been to Habit an heart
attack um my heart rate was not high but
for those who you know watch cartoons as
a kid it was as if my my heart was like
pushing through my my rib cage and it
wasn't like I woke up from a dream that
was you know because if that were the
case my heart R would be high yeah it
wasn't the panic attack no no and it
wouldn't wasn't going down um so I
visited the er um didn't really get much
other than just a bunch of tests nothing
nothing happened and things did ease up
after a little bit but yeah that was
sort of the immediate phase one and it
uh continued it continued and so um
forgive me mhm it took a long time uh in
our regular meetings which were over
Zoom but took a long time for you to say
enough and for me to notice enough to
realize that something was going on with
you you were not uh
talking you may have been open about
this but you certainly weren't uh
bringing it to the four in a way that it
became apparent to me but right um if we
at the point that we finally had a
completely uh clear discussion about the
state of your health you had become
pretty visibly frail compared to what
you had been before and what you are now
um you were so you know what was your
life like and what was your what was
your day-to-day interaction with the the
new medical realities that you were
facing yeah there so I'd say there were
two kind
of two paths or or thing two parallel
paths I would articulate one is the the
physical piece to your point and
managing those symptoms so um I didn't
know what was wrong with me but I knew
there was something wrong and so I tried
various things you would go to your your
standard doctors in Canada U fortunately
unfortunately that may be another
discussion topic for another day but we
have the ability to Access Healthcare in
a in a basic sense at least through the
system that we have uh without um
without pulling out the credit card so
to speak but um yeah test after test
after test was coming back either
negative or all within normal range
which became the bane of my existence
because I know my body pretty well and
knew that you knew something was going
on and they weren't finding it yeah yeah
and so yeah it's one of those things
where it came in different waves but
over time the heart palpitations was
something that would continue um the
wave of fatigue was an issue so it got
to the point where two and a half weeks
after the the dose I took some time off
after that ER visit as well but
um yeah but a week and a half after that
I basically stopped exercising other
than walking for what ended up being
almost a
year um all right and so we can go back
and pick up whatever information we've
uh glossed over but
at some point you did say something
about that you were facing a a vaccine
injury um and that you weren't sure what
to do about it and of course at the
point that that crossed into my
Consciousness fully I know exactly who
to send you to I know the people who
specialize in treating vaccine injured
people and I know that they succeed at
it because you're not the first person
that I've sent right um but I said hey
how about how about we set you up with
Dr Cory and uh you you were up for it of
course you had tried everything and
nothing worked so right up for almost
anything at that point and uh so okay
you uh you met up with Dr Corey
virtually I assume um what happened next
yeah and that was um you know I'm always
grateful for that for that uh
introduction to him well I'm I'm uh
embarrassed that it didn't come earlier
it should I should have paid closer
attention but regardless so we're we're
I was I was grateful for it nonetheless
and it it happened I
think April
mayisha of
22 um so at that point I've gone to your
point I'd gone through any number of of
different Specialists and different
testing and and and uh just straight up
gaslighting from the medical system uh I
have many new opinions of the healthcare
system that I didn't have before but
yeah once I got to that Point um he was
incredibly helpful I think one of the
things I I struggled with was not simply
just the symptoms because at that point
the symptoms were i' gotten into a
Groove where I could manage them now I
still wasn't exercising at that point
other than again just walking and Stu
like that but I had habits around sleep
I had habits around when I would eat and
what I would eat and very very mindful
of all that but to your point I I
um I lost a lot of weight uh I was
probably from where I am right now I was
at the lowest I'm probably 25 lbs
heavier Now versus when I was there
before and I was eating healthy so it
wasn't it wasn't fat it was losing a
fair amount of muscle yeah you you
looked like a different person yeah yeah
so um which also you get to the point
where you start getting conscious about
that too in terms of how you present
right but I was virtual I mean in our
conversation certainly but even in from
a work context I was I was virtual so
you can kind of hide some of it but I
actually Recall now bringing that up I
had a colleague who I hadn't seen in a
while because I moved to a different
team and we met up and she's just like
oh man like you you've lost a lot of
weight in like sort of like a positive
is sort of way right and I kind of you
know just politely uh acknowledged it
and and you know we moved on to the
conversation but that really kind of hit
me and I don't remember exactly when it
was but it was like oh yeah I I
experiencing every day in a sort of
incremental sense but people who haven't
seen me in that Gap it's it's really
noticeable but to your question Dr Corey
was very helpful both because I I needed
two things mainly number one I needed
somebody who actually knew what they
were doing right and he did uh know what
he was doing number two and more almost
more importantly I needed somebody who I
trusted was actually going to do the
their homework because I had
cardiologist to my earlier Point who
basically said to me that okay we don't
see anything on our test
so this must be
psychosomatic and I'm like first of all
you didn't ask any even basic triage
questions to see whether I had any
Mental Health Challenge history number
one number two even if that is what you
think it's going to be or it is you
should at least couch it with your your
patient as you know what I'm not I
haven't really found what's going on
here um you know sometimes there are
scenarios where patients will will um be
so anxious that that physical symptoms
will manifest uh I want to rule that out
so help me help me with this sort of
thing right there's a there's a way to
to veryy with a high level of EQ so to
speak do that right but I got no it must
be all in your head I'm like no it is
most certainly not all in my head and if
it were um well not if it were it just
it it was not and and I know that
because the contrast was so Stark from
pre to post and it wasn't like I didn't
want to like I the fact that I couldn't
play sports or do a lot of the
activities that I was doing before even
just non sports things that just
extended my day too long I'm like no I
can't I can't go too far because it's
I'm going to be so wiped and I didn't
want to affect my job because if I
affected my job then I couldn't pay for
the extra healthc care that I need to
pay out of pocket among many other
things right so yeah it's it's one of
those things where he became a do Dr
Cory became someone who I could trust
that would actually do the homework and
then also as a treatment because one of
the hypothesis I had was that I had
myocarditis and um I'll just say that
that according to him it's very unlikely
that's the case
unfortunately it's uh it's something
that you need some pretty Advanced test
to completely ruled out but the test
that I did do plus the other things that
he kind of took in clinically he didn't
feel like it was that so the easiest way
to describe it was like a very
over-the-top audio immune
response okay um so that's a a powerful
story it's also I will say just the fact
that it's it's not like you're
describing you got the shot you started
to feel Anonymous uh anomalously
terrible um you went to Dr Corey you
started to feel better mhm you're
visibly different mhm right so
psychosomatic doesn't you know it's not
impossible that a person could uh
imagine that they were better and change
their behavior and all of that but you
were trying and it wasn't working and
then uh Dr Corey intervened medically
right and the transition
is uh not only remarkable in its degree
but also remarkable in its speed and you
started reporting as I asked you hey how
is that going um you know it wasn't like
hey I'm better he cured me it's like wow
this is going really well I'm amazed at
at how quickly I'm feeling uh a
difference which you know all of this
suggests an actual intervention that has
physiological implications right um okay
so I should also just
say two things one it is important to me
I I get accused of lots of stuff as you
know um the people who participate in
the discussions that I host the people
who are on the Discord server the people
who circulate around
Darkhorse I do think it is likely that
they are less vaccinated than average if
we were to just see who got shots and
how many less than average but it is
nothing like oh the people who circulate
around Dark Horse didn't get them right
mhm many I think most probably got some
um and this is far from the only store I
know and it's not just people who
circulate around Darkhorse I have
friends people I knew from long before
Co who uh got shots and have very
horrifying stories to tell so there are
a lot of those cases and I also as I
said um have seen people go uh to Dr
Corey finally out of desperation and um
uh this is the report that I get is wow
this is the first time a I felt that the
thing was being dealt with in a logical
way and B the response is undeniable so
that's all very positive I will say just
for people who may be having this
experience um Dr Cory now does tele
medicine and if you're in need of his
help I definitely suggest you uh get a
consult but um
okay the most important thing here is
it's a little bit delicate because
obviously reputationally I have a lot
writing on on this and that's part of
why I've asked you to have this
discussion but certain things that
you've said unprompted by me um I think
are quite telling with respect to where
you are now with your understanding of
what happened during covid what the
reality of the the shots was um and
maybe most importantly where you think
you would be if you hadn't had this
terrible medical Misfortune yeah yeah I
I described to folks that I would put
myself as sort of a Libertarian is
disposition in political ideology prior
to co and still would be there to a
large extent if I'm having to summarize
but the the expectation I had of of
Institutions was that particular in the
covid scenario would be that they would
inefficiently clumsily slowly get there
almost to the right answer right um and
as I've said to you uh I couldn't have
been more wrong on that that realization
took months years to to really see um
but I would say that those smaller
pieces the I mean I used a softball
example earlier it sounds very kind of
mundane but it is a little bit of a a
light bulb moment it's a it's a dimmer
light bulb than than the vaccine issue
but there were some of those types of
moments that started adding up
but still obviously at that point I
still decided I'm going to go ahead with
with getting that shot and yeah it it
changed and I think it's one of those
things
where had I either taken the shot and
and had no adverse ofet um or you know
other sort of scenario I could
definitely see myself going down the
route of many folks of the audience
would be uh very aware of um uh from a
podcast World perspective and just
others in your lives that are the the
quote unquote nor the normies um
who um would have said you know look at
those antivaxers vaccines are amazing
you know etc etc etc and uh you know I
don't try I try not to be the person who
is overtly you know implent rude but
certainly from a thinking perspective I
would have been there for sure and in
fact I was there and had certain things
in addition to just the vaccine thing
which obviously a big one but had other
things not happened yeah I could easily
see myself as as um somebody who would
be pushing back against the so-called
conspiracy theorists and all that sort
of stuff so where do I sit now I'd say
that um I much more skeptical I
am I often will answer questions by
saying I can't rule anything out at this
point yeah it's uh
uh it's a tough position I have to tell
you
because once you are aware of what can
be true I mean in this case we
had a technology that was a radical
departure from the Technologies we knew
and even the Technologies we knew the
truth of them had not been properly
aired MH but this radically new
technology deploy empoyed under false
pretenses and then pushed towards people
who stood to benefit not at all from it
like kids yeah
um that tells you that there's some
Force out there whatever the nature of
it that is willing to do things that put
healthy children in Mortal danger for no
benefit something no rational society
would contemplate right once you know
that that can happen in a particular
context you have to ask yourself the
question is that a unique defect of
Pharma and its interaction with
governance and science or is this a more
General pattern and do I now have to be
alert for this possibility in other
places and of course you don't want to
be somebody
who's constantly looking for nefarious
explanations for things that have
mundane explanations on the other hand
you know that you'd be foolish to assume
that the the mundane explanations had to
be right because that was uh the correct
bias in a prior world right so uh you
know in some sense
I I want to say a welcome and B uh I'm
sorry you know I'm not personally sorry
I don't think I did this to you but I'm
sorry that this happened to you because
what it means is from here on out now
that you're aware nothing's easy it just
can't be you have to do your homework
you're going to make errors you're going
to see stuff that you you think
indicates uh some sort of Nefarious
activity and sometimes it will turn out
not to be sometimes you'll miss
nefarious activity because you're trying
not to be reflexive it's it's just not
an easy position to be in no yeah and
and part of my struggle I think was was
as I would phrase it how do I keep both
my feet on the ground in all this it's
because it is destabilizing yep right
and so it's stabilizing but I also then
uh correspondently knew that stress or
anxiety would worsen my symptoms at the
same time so it's this weird sort of
place that I had to both practically
manage that anxiety by you know moving
on to other things or whenever but also
confront the fact that my worldview had
been at at minimum adjusted if not you
know quite significantly profoundly
changed so you know one of the things
you had you had just mentioned was this
the idea of a force and I think a lot of
people um get caught up in the idea of
of you being conspiratorial by using
that sort of phrasing but how I've
always or at least how I now interpret
what you mean by that is you're
describing a a phenomenon in in a simple
sense right it's a is a series of
different incentives and people and and
things that come together to create a
certain direction in in um in society or
in particular places right and I think
think that uh in general I was too naive
to certain incentives I was too naive
that sociopathic and Psychopathic people
do exist like obviously intell actually
I knew they existed but I was I didn't
appreciate that those people do often
get into places where they can wield
disproportionate power and then I I
honestly one of the one of the most
concerning things that I'd learned about
people around us
um in general is there's a lot of
compliant people and as you were
alluding to I think I would have been
one of those people because I would have
not in a sort of you know you are a bad
person sort of way I I just don't think
I'm dispositionally you know structured
that way but certainly in my mind those
people are not doing their part you know
those people aren't reading the research
or whatever the phrasing would be in my
head uh but the as you've used the word
too the brown shirting of of
folks around me in general luckily my
closer friends are I'd say more normies
but not the they don't wear brown shirts
let's just put it that way uh
fortunately and that was also very
helpful in my recovery process too that
it took a little bit of stress off but
but yeah even just I didn't even tell my
my mom about it
until five plus months later yeah that's
amazing um partly partly because I
didn't want her to worry right as as
moms would do but also because like the
burden of her taking that on and sort of
like managing it that like I I wasn't
going to be worried about her response
to me and that she was going to cast me
away kind of thing it was more so the
stress of her her reaction and the
burden that she would kind of have to
take on in conversations with other
people it just it didn't make sense that
fortunately one of my siblings is a is a
nurse and you know we've been coming you
know we had all this classic sibling
rivalry as we were younger but over time
um we've gotten pretty close and pretty
much she was the only one that knew
other than a few other friends um early
on for both practical and and other
reasons and so yeah it affected all
those different relationships and and um
yeah the the worldview gets adjusted
quite significantly when you go through
those those changes and so it's also
given me a lot of empathy for folks who
have gone through either other types of
health challenges that are completely
ignored or gaset or non-health but
otherwise you know experiencing things
seeing things or whatever I don't have
to neily agree believe accept their
premises but as far as I'm concerned at
the very least I'm going to hear them
out I'm going to give them the time
obviously you can't give the time to
every single person that you ever come
across especially someone like you but
in principle that's where I am and I I
think I was much
more um I was much less generous before
and I and I regret that but I'm here now
so well I think actually you've hit on
the most important Insight from all of
this which is that your social
connections have to
be uh robust to differences even
profound differences even differences
that depending upon who's right have
life and death implications the point is
if you're on honly trying to figure out
what's going on and you're wrong and the
way you're wrong puts people in
Jeopardy the right thing to do is to
attempt to persuade you and maybe you'll
persuade me right um the wrong thing to
do is to imagine that if your conclusion
is incorrect and potentially harmful
that that is a moral defect that you are
displaying because it isn't right if
you've done if your analytical process
leads you to a conclusion usion you're
open to the possibility of changing it
and you act based on what you have
concluded with the best tools that your
disposal who can fault you for that it's
not a moral defect it might be an
analytical one but that's it and so
anyway I think the idea
that I mean some of the other people I
know who have stories and frankly some
of them are worse than yours um as I
said I'm very great as bad as this was
um I'm very grateful that it wasn't
nearly as bad as many others have had it
many others and it's funny you know in
in it's it's the opposite of funny right
in my circle you know I don't know how
representative my circle is I don't know
how evenly distributed the injuries were
I don't know how um you know my circle
is odd because it's unusually large I've
been put in contact with a lot of people
by uh events since 2017 but several of
the people I know who have serious
injuries
are well-known people who have not
talked about it publicly and the idea
that something would put you in the
predicament where you had been injured
you tried to do the right thing you Tred
to do something that was uh pro-social
as the as the term is and it went badly
for you you were injured there are lots
of people who claim injury who are being
portrayed as psycholog ically defective
and you're quiet about it even though
you have personal experience you could
say hey look I don't know maybe I'm an
anomaly but I had a terrible experience
with this thing let me tell you about it
in what Universe are people who are in
general bold about talking about
heterodox ideas unwilling to share their
experience the that suggests you know go
go back to the point about a force I
don't know what the force is I'm not you
know I'm agnostic about yes is there's
definitely some conspiracy here but
there's also some emergent property of
the way uh social phenomena unfold and
I'm uh agnostic as to where the balance
point is what fraction of this is
actually you know you know that we got
to where we are and so something has
right got as here I what I can see is
it's just like uh the discovery of a
planet that you haven't spotted yet
where you detect the something has is
exerting a gravitational impact on uh
some other body and so the point is well
I don't know what that is but I can tell
how powerful it is I can tell how much
mass it's got um and this is like that
um the fact that there is a force that
gets people to self censor their own yes
anecdotal but
significant uh reaction to one of these
vaccines to me suggests a very very
powerful social force that causes people
uh who are ordinarily biased in the
direction of sharing information to um
to protect a story that that actually
harmed them which is an amazing
fact yeah I
mean gives you a sense to give you a
sense of sort the gas liting piece
because I think it's related to this um
so I mentioned the cardiologist uh piece
I also went went to my my general
practitioner family doctor I'm not sure
what the Yankees talk call it but uh I'm
not sure if you're technically a Yankee
given where you are in the world but um
I went to my my doctor with not a whole
lot of expect expectations just
basically hoping that she can do some
basic um you
know checkup type stuff and see if
something she'll she'll find and also
the way the Canadian system works it's
very I know
other systems are similar but the
Canadian system is very dependent on
that that uh GP to be um who refers you
out to the various other Specialists
right so I kind of needed to to go
through her but went to this this
uh uh appointment and by the end of the
appointment she basically said
everything seems pretty good and you
know I was expecting that I wasn't
expecting to get some new insight
necessarily but I said let's let's
try but as I was walking out the door
she says um so when are you going to get
your your next
dose and you know I think you know me
enough to know that I'm not a
particularly emotive person uh it took a
lot of energy for me not to Just Lose It
in that moment uh so there's probably
was a good like one to three seconds of
just like breathing right and then you
know letting it go but I bring that up
it's it's it's so ridiculous that it's
almost comical
but that is the experience a lot of a
lot of folks um I had somebody I did go
quasi public in January of 2020 sorry
2022 that that timeline wouldn't work U
of
2022 before the you know as a as a canu
the before the trucker protest because
the conversation in Canada was was
lurching towards mandatory
vaccinations and at that point um for
obvious reasons I was not not interested
in getting a second one and that would
have made me up to date or whatever the
phrasing is now um so I did the video
didn't really get a lot of traction but
I just viscerally needed to say
something I could not say something and
I needed to figure out the way to do it
and a constructive way and all those
other things that are are important to
me but I could not say something and
after that video I had a couple people
reach out to me and honestly of course
right someone I I knew from school that
had seen in a while and he had the exact
same issues that I had
um and you know I had some people who
responded in a more public way who were
who were uh let's just say skeptical of
my of my claims and my skepticism
towards mandatory vaccinations or very
other other forms of things like they'll
they'll bring up sort of school
vaccinations and make the comparison
there which I think is both um wrong but
also U has some residence but I I don't
think it's completely relevant to the
the topic area of the time but it's it
was um it was it's quite interesting and
so to your point someone like me who
generally I I'm I wouldn't call myself
an open book like if I'm more open than
I ever used to be in general but I'm not
the first person to be default open but
if I had a health issue I would have
been in in non-co non super
controversial political topic areas I
would have been open enough to talk to
people who would have been able to
support me in different ways right in
this case one of the biggest problems is
that not only was the healthcare system
not responding to me in the ways that I
needed but it was very difficult to
reach out to other people who might have
had ideas for other people to for me to
reach out to like other family or
friends who are have connections in the
healthcare system and stuff like that so
I had to couch everything that I said
and and because I didn't want people to
feel like I was crazy CU if if that was
the case then they W me off right it's
like oh man the pandemic's really
affected too kind of thing right so like
it was always that sort of I don't want
to over oversell it um but that
cognitive load if you will of trying to
communicate the right way and then
trying to manage your symptoms and then
all these different things it was the
symptoms were exhausting then the
additional mental load was
exhausting and um you know fortunately I
don't have to do that now but that's
probably one of the reasons why it took
so long for me to get to to that result
that I at now so we are so far from
any normal acceptable system that it's
hard to even fathom how far that story
is from
reasonable let's say that the universe
is the one that you described you would
have assumed was going to happen where
the system would be too bureaucratic it
would Bumble its way towards the right
answer too slowly with too much Carnage
but whatever it would get there yeah
in that
world okay they should never have said
it's totally safe because no drug is
right the chances this was going to be
totally safe for zero it's safe enough
they could have made that error mhm if
they did make that error and you were
the Unlucky Guy the one in a million who
had some weird reaction based on some
unusual bit of your physiology
interacting with the shot or some
contaminant in the shot that was very
very rare or something like that who the
hell is anybody not to just simply say
that really sucks that this shot hurt
you I understand it's a very rare
phenomenon but what does that mean to
you you got hurt so from my perspective
for me it's one for one right right the
gaslighting of the vaccine injured
is so
deeply callous and
inhuman that it is hard for me to
imagine
people The Architects of it and I know
that some of it is emerging for example
doctors who fell for this and
administered it to their patients or
strong armed them into getting it or
whatever they did those doctors many of
them do not have the strength of
character to face their own
responsibility and so they are
rationalizing what they did and in
rationalizing what they did they are
dismissing people who are injured in
front of them as having psychosomatic
illness I know there's some of that mhm
but there's also people you know the
people who took the vaccine injured and
shut down their Facebook group so these
people couldn't even you know never mind
whether they were going to find some
sort of a treatment and there are
obviously treatments that work but just
even the ability to join other people
who were injured and say yeah that's
happening to me too I also have tentis
that I can barely stand right yeah
the ability just simply to make human
contact with other people who are in a
similar situation that is the right of
the injured and the the force that
disrupts that right by throwing them off
Facebook and demonizing them as if
they're making this up in order to uh it
just insan you know to even just the
idea that the word antivaxer comes up
here you're talking about people who
took the vaccine yeah they're not
antivaxers or if they are now they're
antivaxers with a justification
so yeah um I don't know I find I find
the degree to which people are
self-editing and worried about what
others will say the degree to which
people are willing to reach out to you
and you know to your face tell you that
uh you're not on the team because you're
talking about some experience that you
had this is this is madness yeah um I
would also say I don't know what I would
have done in your shoes with this Doctor
Who asked when you were getting your
next dose but I think uh um what I would
like to have done if had I been in your
shoes would be something like say good
one doc you had me for a
second honestly like that that probably
would have been a good response but I I
think I was just so shocked
that you know I I could imagine her
thinking it but for her to be so like
matter of fact not even even just what
she said wasn't even the problem it was
just so matter of fact it was okay you
know here's the check checklist and
we're we're going through it's you're a
few months few months late but you know
you get your second one you're you can
participate in society again right
because at that point you know a lot of
places in the world at that point it was
probably two and a bit months in of of
uh passports right so but no I'm I'm
going to push back on you a little bit
okay you've got a doctor mhm who has in
front of them someone
who at
least is exper experiencing some massive
disruption of their life right that
occurred who was healthy got a shot and
is having a massive
unexplained disruption of their
physiological
life to ask that person when they are
getting their next dose of the same
stuff is to reveal that this person has
no logical capacity that medical
training was wasted on them because the
fact is it is readily possible that your
experience is the result of an anomaly
of your physiology either you've picked
up an allergy to some ingredient in the
vaccine or you have some uh rare genetic
predisposition to Etc but the idea that
somebody who has had that
experience this doctor should be
recommending oh listen Nick I think
everybody should get these shots but not
you in fact you know
that would at least be consistent with
some Universe in which logic holds um or
or the very least it's not you know when
are you getting your next dose is it's a
you know maybe even if she thinks I
ought to it's are you going to get your
next dose right and let's talk about
this there's at least something to
discuss rather than um okay well I've
done my due diligence and we're now on
the uh the part of the uh the
appointment where we closed things down
and we asked the regular questions right
and well the the the the absurdity now
that I think about it the absurdity even
further is at that point this was
November 2022 right we knew a lot of
things at this point in terms of the not
just the safety profile put that aside
the utility of it the any there a little
weasel words here but effic uh eff
efficacy Effectiveness but I'll I'll
just say utility right and we knew at
that point that the transmission
argument was dead in the water even
though the passports were alive and well
at that point and so why why someone who
you literally just examined right and
have records for not many because I
wasn't there very often because I didn't
need to be but you had records for why
would I need personally to get another
shot even regardless of whether you
think the shot caused my my current
issues right right so like on on at
least two or three different levels it
was an absurd question
right an assertion on on her part right
and you know I don't I I don't bring her
name up um for a reason because I don't
think it's relevant but it does it does
show that smart people have the have
more Tools in their toolbox to deceive
themselves right and po post talk
rationalize and I think some of the
doctors you were mentioning I think
probably fall in that same camp right
there's a there's a courage ele but
there's also the the post talk
rationalization that they tie the bow on
which is when you reveal on the surface
which is simply uh you know an
undermining of Integrity or a lack of
courage or whatever it is right like
there are ways to still be in line with
your values but maybe not necessarily be
out in the open right there there's
different roles people can play in in a
world like this right not everyone has
to have a podcast not everyone has to
have a big platform but there are ways
to act with Integrity that don't include
you know just going along with every
single dictate right or even just being
kind of strategic about it right in her
case she could have maybe said you know
I don't know the the idea of an
exemption never came up which also now I
think about is kind of interesting but
there are many ways between fully public
you know someone like yourself fully
public in you know everyone's
criticizing you for for your point of
view and then you know fully
right on mainstream kind of view there's
a lot of ways that you can maneuver
within this space that are not just
sitting there especially if you are
aware implicitly or many explicitly that
something is off here right and
personally not withstanding this this
conversation my my Approach has been I'm
not going to participate or you know U
I'll Le maybe comply I suppose to absurd
things right so the mandatory
vaccination thing I was like okay I need
to get ready for the fact that I'm not
going to take this and take the take the
uh you know whatever the backlash is or
the consequences of that are like
literally to the point where I'm like I
need to think about options made to get
to the
US now fortunately that conversation
died after you know a good week and a
half um due to maybe the truckers and
other things but but um it's it's I
guess to folks who are listening like
you do not have to be Brett who has the
platform and and the kind of the moral
courage to talk about these things to
make a difference right you don't have
to you just I think it's really you know
I talked to you where I was coming from
this week was kind of a leadership
conference and one of the conversation
points was the core of leadership is the
the values the the Integrity that kind
of underg all of it all the different
skills and and you know EQ and and all
these different other things that stack
on top of that those are important
they're useful they're skills if you
don't have that Foundation none of it
matters and if your values evaporate in
the face of pressure then they're not
they're they're fashion statement yeah
they're not they're not values in the in
the deeply meaningful sense of the term
right um and I I agree with you and I I
have been I think too cautious actually
in pushing people to stand up and this
was true before Co this was true uh with
the the woke Madness too and the reason
I was very explicit about why I was
reluctant to push people to stand up
it's not that I don't want them to stand
up I do but I don't want them to stand
up because I suggest that if you do that
and even just the example of me suggest
that if you do that it won't be
catastrophic mhm they've done terrible
things to Heather and me but we're still
doing fine so um that example could be
misleading if you if you're in a
position you know happens we don't work
for anybody right so they could
interrupt our ability to earn they and
they
did powerfully but nobody can fire us so
we're in a good position to stand up
somebody who works for a boss who's
going to fire them either out of a
misunderstanding of what's motivating
them or out of some fear of their own
that if they don't they will be next in
line um that person may not be in a
position to stand up but it does doesn't
mean that they have to be um on board
with the madness it doesn't mean they
have to be part of it and the um the
thing that is I don't want to say most
conspicuous but at at the top of that
list are a number of things one of them
is the system is not reacting the way a
system that had made an honest error
would react there is not you know yes
there would be ask covering in that case
but there would also be
uh maybe
grudging
um discussion of how can we make sure
this never happened again there would be
uh
scapegoating right there would be all
sorts of stuff in you know exactly an
analogous process to the system
stumbling its way to the right answer
right if we were all let's put it this
way if they weren't willing to do the
harm they did then the fact that they
had accidentally done all of this harm
would be causing the system to function
in a way that it is not it is still
gaslighting it is still pushing the same
damn shots it is still pushing them
towards kids it it's pushing mandates
again right it's pushing mandates again
right um and as you point out among the
many absurdities here we know they don't
block transmission and we know that the
hospitals aren't overwhelmed what
businesses it of theirs if you get a
shot even if their point is it will
protect you from the worst uh outcomes
which is not not true but even if it
even even on that point right like it
it's absurd on its face so put aside the
transmission argument because we know
that even though people still deploy it
they're half-heartedly just deploying it
and anyone with just a pair of eyes can
see that it's not it doesn't work on
right like it's just it just doesn't
work that said you know the the m and
Bailey sort of approach here is to start
with the transmission argument and pull
back to oh well it's preventing severe
disease or mitigating severe disease and
and and supporting the hospitals on on
that basis right which is even a more
powerful argument in Canada because of
the you know the Public Health Care
System right but even on that argument
right it's like okay let's look at that
let's look at the data because one of
the things in my day job I do you know I
do look into into Data I'm not some
super wizard with it but I have I have
basic skills to to look through data and
if you looked probably if fall 2021 into
2022 the people who were going to
emergency rooms were vaccinated old
people MH right right so it's like okay
that maybe if I'm generous maybe there
would be more of those older people if
they didn't have the vaccine right right
but it's only them and and then the
gamees played around what it what is a
hospitalization right what does that
actually mean right and all those
different like the stack of the of the
games the data manipulations not even
just from a like we made up the raw data
like I don't even think they in the case
of the public data you don't have to
assume let's put it this way you don't
have to assume that the data was made up
in order to still see the absurdity here
yeah right it's just the the phrasing
it's the it's the discussion there on on
that basis but so you don't you don't
even have that argument but if you go
even
further the impact the relative impact
of getting X more people vaccinated even
on the best
numbers still wouldn't make much of an
impact on any particular Hospital
especially because it's it's completely
untargeted it would it wouldn't make any
impact on any given hospital it also
would be an extremely powerful argument
for age stratification because the point
is certain number of people are going to
the hospital or Worse dying who weren't
going to end up in the hospital from
covid right so those people should be
insulated from both things they are
already predisposed not to suffer from
covid we should protect them from the
shots and the fact that we don't have
that conversation is
conspicuous and then you get into the
really deep stuff and it's like well all
right if you are saying that we have a
collective responsibility to take these
shots
because something something hospitals
overwhelm severe effect something like
that then the evidence that those those
who have gotten many doses have igg4
triggered and that seems to be
downregulating the immune system can we
at least agree that if the shots getting
many of them turns out to downregulate
your immune system in a way that makes
you more likely to get covid and makes
you more likely to contract other
diseases that were that true that you
should be recommending against the shots
for everybody can we just at least get
there if it's true you'll recommend
against and the answer is no no no we're
going to be recommending for no matter
what what we're going to do is rearrange
the s so that they explain why we're
recommending for the shots but the
sacred thing here is we will recommend
the shots and it's like whoa that does
they have a conclusion now we're looking
for the evidence we're looking for yeah
we're looking for the the justification
and it's like well that doesn't sound
scientific or medical or anything that
sounds uh at at best that sounds like
business in a slightly different note it
it also reminds me of earlier in the
conversation we talked about how people
are deducing values from certain
political stances right and so it's
almost the the reverse we ought to align
on values RIT large whether it's what we
want to see in the world or just sort of
how we act in the world and then flowing
from that there may be disagreements on
on how and what we do and stuff like
that liberal conservative whatever
phrasing you want to use but the problem
is we are doing it in the reverse way
it's what is your position on vaccines
what is your position on other
controvertial ABC issues and deducing
that's what your values are now it's not
completely unrelated obviously you know
you can deduce something from those
things in fact ironically you could
probably deduced more because of the
polarization but I think we undermine
the Dignity of human beings and the
ability to bring people together if we
start in that way you might get Clues on
that but try to transcend that and have
those conversations cuz look
like you and I you know we know know
each other pretty well but we don't know
each other like super in depth but you
and I disagree on on certain things and
i' I've come to your position on on more
things appropo to this conversation but
as far as I'm concerned I don't feel an
obligation to believe everything that
you say right right I just listen
because I think you have insights I
listen to other people who have insights
whether they are kind of mainstream
people or people you know on anywhere on
the map sort of thing and I I I've
opened that that um that space a lot
more than I had in the past but the key
thing for me is that is there an insight
there even if it's buried in a lot of
right is there something to
that that I can that I can chew on that
I can work with even if you think of it
from you know folks in the audience who
who may be interested in the sort of
investment space or or venture capital
and stuff like that that's how or Angel
Investing that that's how they think
they think about where do I find the
novel insights that other people aren't
paying attention to yeah and so apply
that mindset to your life outside of
investing in terms of how I affect how I
work on my health how I look at my
professional life how do I work and
support people around me in terms of
relationships right like that is that is
a useful skill set instead what we're
calling critical thinking is I'm
defaulting I have a proxy and my proxy
is you know Journal AB or C it's you
know doctor on CNN or in my case C DC
right or any number of those things and
I was playing that proxy game too but
it's okay to proxy proxying is okay but
know that it's a proxy it's not answer
know where you're doing it yeah exactly
you got to know where that flow of
proxying is happening because we can't
do the all the way down to 0 zero of
everything right or first of all we
would drive us insane second of all we
don't have the capacity or the time
right yeah so I I love this point I
think I think it's a um it's a gorgeous
it's a gorgeous point the uh the
tendency the ability to spot what others
are missing is almost synonymous with
intelligence MH right that is what when
we say that somebody is intelligent
that's what we mean we don't mean that
they are better at following the you
know they're better at reciting facts
sure what we mean is that they can see
what others can't or they see what
others will eventually see sooner or
something like that yeah so the idea
that we have now uh valorized the degree
to which you adhere to a slate of stated
beliefs rather than the degree to which
you depart in a way that goes on to uh
be uh preent um that turns out to have
been preent that that is US turning
Intelligence on its head yeah and I
think there I think there is something
to be said though that that description
I think is true however I would add
that I think people who otherwise have
this the skill set or the raw you know
intellect power are being basically you
know it's almost as if they they have
two sheets of paper or something to the
two sides of their of their head that
they can only see in front of them and
they'll just deal with a phenomenon that
they can see right and so some to your
point force incentives uh the way that
our culture works we've kind of put up
these walls and we only see what's in
front and until you're able to you know
open up that periphery and take on the
the obligations and the and the um
difficulty that comes with that frankly
right especially when it first
happens um we will not be able to first
of all find interesting insights just in
general but also solve big problems
because I don't care what the issue is
whether it's co related or
otherwise the biggest meta Challen
challenge as far as I'm concerned is our
inability to solve challenges period and
have conversation and and transcend even
the most difficult problem areas right
by to your point aligning on where do we
agree where do we don't what what are
those value sets that can bring us
together what even just what are the
things we can do that that um show the
humanity in each of us and then you know
come to the table so to speak and work
on work on the problems until we have
the ability to do that it doesn't matter
what the issue is we're not going to
solve it and in fact we're going to make
it worse because certain people are
literally or figuratively profiting from
the inability of people to solve those
problems it occurs to me uh in your
description you think about what it
means that somebody has been
framed right when we when we say that
that person was framed for a crime yeah
what we mean is I mean we're literally
it's an analogy to a picture frame that
a picture has been painted in which this
person looks guilty yeah and what you're
describing the uh the blinders is a
matter of something having framed a
pandemic that
causes certain things to follow
logically from it if you accept the
blinders then the picture looks
completely coherent right if you throw
away the blinders you know it's pkin in
its own way right that looks like a town
but if you go around the back it's a set
right um that's an important distinction
and so part of the problem of
communicating this to people is I'm not
saying that you don't see what you say
you see right I'm telling you to stand
somewhere else right then you will see
what I see right and if people are
unwilling to do that and this is the key
the reason that they demonize us morally
is that the why would I standy told me
to stand there would I go and it's like
okay but you've just accepted a
formulation that makes it impossible for
you to go through an exercise which I
swear will cause the scales to fall from
your eyes and you're telling me it's for
moral reasons and the point is morality
does not enter into this it's analytical
yeah well I mentioned this to you before
too but I won't go into the story too
much but simply to say that I had a
friend of mine this is this sort of
illustrates the cognitive dissonance
right all of us have Cog distance all
like I everything I've said today I'm a
I'm a flawed human being just like
anyone else and maybe maybe more so oh
definitely more so that's right that's
right yeah um we need a lot more time to
to list all the explore that oh I don't
think there isn't enough that's right
that's right that's right that yeah yeah
even YouTube would run out of recording
space uh it would be him to yeah but I
had a had a friend of mine who was both
one of the most supportive people during
my health
Journey but also one of the most
over-the-top
um you
know declares of his uh adherence to the
to the various narratives right in terms
of you know those antivaxers are
screwing it up for all of us and blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah right but
it was it was an interesting insight for
me because he literally was one of the
only people who reached out to me on a
regular basis at least a few times a
week so hey how you doing how you
feeling right I played sports with him
so one of one of the things that he
would notice is that I'm not on playing
those sports with him yeah right um so
there is that capacity in people to both
have that sort of you know I'm going to
be supportive and caring to somebody I
know but then also play this other sort
of virtue signaling game and again I'm
not trying to be cones understanding
because I've played those games in the
past too yeah right no no and probably
will in the future in some way this is
this is perfect because for one thing I
don't I don't know who you're talking
about I'm sure I don't know him but
um I have a lot of Hope for that person
because what did not happen was they did
not shut down his his sympathy right for
a friend exactly and so his humanity is
intact even if his analytics have been
captured right um so definitely
recoverable but I also find an
interesting analogy I mean you're
drawing the analogy yourself but an
analogy uh to you and your journey here
M because um well let me let me ask you
I'm uh working from knowledge outside of
our conversation here but uh you were a
Sam Harris
fan yes okay um I think this is
important and I actually hope Sam will
watch this um you were a Sam Harris fan
and one of the things that you said that
struck me very
powerfully
after I think after you had been begun
to be treated uh for your injury mhm was
that absent your
Misfortune that you would probably be
ballpark where Sam Harris is ballpark
where Sam Harris is y
and uh that that struck me profoundly
because of course you know Sam is or was
a friend and he's been terrible to
Heather and me over CO as you know uh
and
I think he
imagines all sorts of moral
defects uh in people who disagree with
him and he does not understand where
this is coming from and anyway I think
um your ability to still to not flinch
from looking at where you think you
would be if you hadn't had the personal
experience that woke you up
um Sam does not know how many of the
people who are most angry at him
actually are fans of his who uh are
deeply disappointed and feel betrayed by
his straying from Central features of
his own uh his own philosophy right the
the moral
imperative uh not to lie for example the
story we were given was riddled with
lies and he's he's doubled down again
and again over them um his position that
you know we have two choices one of them
is to have difficult conversations and
the other is violence and yet he refuses
to talk so anyway I hope that maybe he
and others who are in the same place can
hear here's somebody who would be with
us potentially and I don't necessarily
know that you would but I think the fact
that you're willing to to entertain that
possibility
um but had an experience that is just
simply incompatible with Landing there
that's all you need to know right Sam
there but for the grace of God go you
right and you know I hate to put it in
religious terms but Sam this is part of
it right I I think it's I think that's
the key and the way that I that I phrase
it I mean I don't know I don't know Sam
I only know him through through the
podcast and you know the YouTube world
when I went through my
my quasi atheist phase I'm not a
religious person but I wouldn't call
myself an atheist at this point but so I
was intr introduced to him that way and
then I thought he was particularly good
on preo issues in in many ways um didn't
agree with him on everything but he's a
different human being so therefore of
course I don't agree with him on
everything I know I make that point a
lot with with friends and stuff like
that but it's just we know that but we
don't internalize that point that uh if
you if you're only 99% in agreement
which is probably still quite rare um
you know that 1% makes us a moral a
moral hazard or some moral defect in
some way right but yeah I think it's
just incredibly important to have the
humility to understand that you know
this also sounds quasi religious too but
the humility to know that you are also
flawed that you are affected by the same
phenomena that you that one might be
describing around the world and and
affecting other people you were affected
by it too you might be affected
differently but you were affected by it
too and absent other circumstances you
may be falling in different places and
to your point I identified I to your
point I don't know it's it's projecting
on a on a other scenario that we don't
know exactly where it would go but
um the defaulting the proxy point I was
making earlier I think one of the the
flaws that Sam has in this case is that
he thinks his evidence um his his
evidence is
proxies right yeah more often than not
yeah his evidence is proxies which
amounts to appeals to
Authority in most people's case they
don't know how the immune system works
they don't know you know how the image
in the textbook differs from the actual
physiology they don't they're not in a
position to judge this and to Sam's
credit Sam says he's not in a position
to judge it but what he does that
doesn't make sense is he projects that
onto for example Heather and me right
and he says you don't know anything
about this space just the same way I Sam
don't know anything about the space and
that's dead wrong and you know we I
don't want to go
after uh Sam's capacity to uh to analyze
this stuff but the fact is there is a
discussion to be had about you know it's
not the degree that makes you qualified
it's whether or not you have the
background information to extrapolate in
a way that is more insightful than it is
misleading and uh Sam doesn't have it he
knows that but he just assumes that that
must be true of anyone who departs from
The Narrative rather than there's
something wrong with the engine that's
generating The Narrative it is heavily
influenced at the very least by powerful
forces with perverse incentives yeah I
think
ultimately when you look at someone like
like Sam um I see somebody who who yeah
has so those direct appeals to Authority
and but at the same time you know he
does this but I think it's a broader
phenomenon too we often will see that
that folks who kind of accept the more
mainstream approach to the issues we've
been facing over the past few years not
just Co but more broadly they will
appeal to oh expert a which has you know
epidemiologist or cardiologist or
whatever it's like okay all right well
they C they in principle would have some
sort of tool set to evaluate the issues
that might be at hand but then you pull
out those very same titles and
backgrounds and stuff like that who
disagree right slightly or even
profoundly and it's like oh no they're
they're cranks it's like okay but who is
deciding that they are cranks right
right they might be cranks right it
could very well be the case but who is
deciding that much like how people will
say well don't do your research right
and I and I've you know again humility
I've definitely said that sort of thing
or made jokes to that effect with with
other people but fundamentally and I'll
still probably make jokes some effect
almost in a just an ironic way but
fundamentally if you are again in my
maybe in my health uh Journey as well
but in general when people go to the
doctor and they get an opinion from the
doctor on something and then they go to
another doctor and get a second opinion
on
something who's going to decide which
opinion you're going with right and you
know if the two opinions agree that
tells you something but often they don't
that's why you would get a second one
that's why that used to be the wisdom
right but you get a second opinion you
get maybe a third opinion whatever but
ultimately my point is you as the
non-expert quot are still going to have
to make the call right which may be
based on who you think is more likely to
be right it may be based on a
calculation that
is influenced by your values in other
words um how much do I want to extend my
life at all costs and how much would I
rather um you know increase the quality
of my life at some risk to shortening it
those things could cause you to decide
one way or the other you know am I going
to throw caution to the wind and assume
that I don't or whatever it is but yeah
um but to your
point and this again I don't mean to
focus on Sam here
but the
doctors the dissident
doctors that group includes some of the
most highly published doctors in their
fields and their work was not based on a
guess it was based on proper medicine
they detected patterns they chased them
down and those patterns are manif
in uh in experiment where if you know
where to look to demonize them as Cooks
to portray them as out of their depth as
grifters as you know Sam went to the
point of hypothesizing that they might
be
schizophrenic right the point is okay
well that's you
know possible Right the rain the realm
of possibility includes that they are
schizophrenic it also Sam includes the
possibility that you are schizophrenic
right but the incredibly deep
publication record and the history of
innovating uh uh treatments that are now
standard of care for multiple different
disorders this is not consistent with a
world in which these people are
lightweights and what you are saying is
that people who were at the top of their
field are now cranks have thrown away
their careers over nothing over insanity
or over uh perverse incentive does that
make sense does that make more sense
than a world in which uh Pharma which
has an obvious perverse incentive
captured doctors and turned most of them
into puppets people who are not highly
published in their fields which of these
is more likely you know this is the kind
of question that Sam used to be very
good at yeah if you take but the thing
is we we are sort of fed these one L
liners around oh okay he's a grifter or
you know this person is a crank or
whatever the line is and but there's
also sort of an incentive H going back
to my point around doing your own
research to not look at it right it's
sort of like this smoke signal this this
uh odor that is thrown over and again
MPA like I definitely have fallen victim
to avoiding the stench so to speak of of
folks who might have insights that I
otherwise could have used in some ways
in the past and so now my my Approach is
I'm very aware that that you know a
skunk may have been in this area so to
speak because other people have thrown
the the the odor down but I'm interested
again I'm interested in the inside I
have might have to really search and
really you know claw my way to find it
but I'm interested in the insight and
there are certain things that I'm
getting better at in understanding who
has those insights and for what reasons
and what value sort of undergirded and
their their approaches their Styles and
you know I'll have my revised version of
proxies but again I know who my proxies
are or at least I yeah I am very
conscious of of identifying where I am
proxying well the other the other thing
if I can just extrapolate from the story
that you've told if the same scenario
went down again with a different virus
different highly novel shots
whatever you would still not know who
knew what they were talking about for
sure right but if you could read the
basics the basics are I am not heavily
threatened by this
disease in fact I'm probably not in
serious danger at all I'm likely to get
it but I'm likely to come through
it there is no long-term information on
the impact of this new technology that
I'm being told to get MH I know that I'm
being told that it is highly effective
at preventing the transmission of
disease but I know that the voices that
say that have lied to me before MH
they've told me that they knew it
blocked transmission and then it turned
out years later that they had no basis
for saying such a thing and they
probably knew it didn't wasn't true but
they said they didn't say it right and
then they tried to memory hold their
having said if you had those facts and
then the point is yes but I'm
being coerced I have to get this shot
because I'm not going to be allowed to
participate in society you would
undoubtedly choose to accept a higher
cost to avoid the much larger unknown of
the consequence of that shot because you
know what can lurk behind that door yeah
um and that is you know I I hate that
this lesson had to come to you this way
I hope that what's happened is you have
have
um fully recovered and nothing lurks
from your your one uh inoculation MH
um but if that's what happened in some
ways that's a that's a gift it's an
incredibly powerful lesson you you say
that uh and and that's kind of the
phrasing that I I was saying while I was
working on the recovery I said to the
people who did know I said that
I when if whatever phrasing I would use
at the time I get through this this will
be among the greatest gifts I've ever
been given and I do believe that um it
was profoundly the biggest challenge in
my life
um at you know and I always want to
emphasize that it was bad but I had it
much less um than many other folks had
it right and so I'm always conscious of
that but but um yeah I mean sometimes
sometimes that's what is required in
life life you need certain some people
need a nudge some people need a little
tap on the shoulder and sometimes you
need to be fully shaken before you uh
see certain things that you wouldn't see
otherwise and you know who knows what
that trajectory would have been absent
of this to your earlier point but I am
where I am and and I'm still learning
I'm still you know figuring things out
as I go and and I would just say in
general
that I my values have not changed from
where I was pre-2020 my view on the
world and how it operates has changed
right but my values have not changed in
fact I almost kind of scraped through a
little bit and noticed certain things
that were almost kind of suppressed in a
in a value sense because I just wasn't
think of it or it was so deep in proxies
and all these different things and um I
think it's for for folks out there who
may otherwise not be
don't find my message endearing don't
find my story endearing or otherwise uh
you know dismiss me you know fair enough
that's that's your prerogative but just
I would just hope that you give yourself
a moment to
think am I also being a little um am I
am I lacking humility here and you don't
have to agree with what I'm saying what
Brett's saying what anyone's saying but
do I have a little bit of humility to
understand that I don't I couldn't
possibly know how the world Works in a
full fullsome sense and the way that the
last few years has worked out there's no
way that your model even if it predicted
relatively well that your model would
ever get to what we what we saw even for
folks like yourself your model changed
over time now you had a pretty good
model going into it but it certainly
changed even I'd say significantly right
yep um and so just at least start with a
humility notwithstanding anything else
that we've that we've talked about and
if you start there that's great and also
just maybe the first thing with that
humility is to rebuild that
bridge if possible with that person that
that you have either been estranged from
or otherwise uh we possible I know it's
not possible in many cases but I think
it's um it's a deep deep thing that we
all crave as human beings for that
connection and uh whenever you can
rebuild a bridge that that has been
burnt down um it's a tough but a
rewarding experience and um you know not
withstanding everything that has been
talked about today I think that that's
at least the foundational step and it
sounds like it's so divorced from talk
about you know side effects from a from
some sort of healthcare intervention and
going through the system and all sort of
stuff
butare inter intervention
what is a is Downstream from the
fundamentals the first principles of how
do we communicate with each other what
are our values and um are we mindful
that as human beings that we're not only
flawed but also can't possibly know
everything that's going on in the world
so you must be able you must be open at
least to some extent to information that
you might otherwise be dismissive of
yeah and let me uh
uh add a little precision to your
example
here we know that people were injured by
these shots everybody acknowledges that
even fer acknowledges this
right that means that when you're
dealing with somebody who's telling you
that they had an injury you might be
dealing with a very rare unlucky person
but you're not dealing with a morally
defective person and the point is the
real question if you think these shots
were a slam dunk um you have to
acknowledge that the cost of that slam
dunk was some number of people got hurt
and the question is somebody got hit by
the ball when it went through the hoop
so to speak how many yeah how many if
it's a tiny number then if it's a tiny
number and the shots are effective and
the evidence that suggests they're not
is somehow in error then the point is
yeah okay these are shots that have a
cost of X that is the number of people
who are hurt and how badly they are
injured MH and they have a benefit which
is why and you can compare these things
and do a cost benefit analysis and then
you would do something smart like Risk
stratification based on age MH um if
you're demonizing people because they
say they were
hurt you have a moral problem that's an
actual moral problem mhm you're not
allowed to demonize people who tried to
do the right thing and got unlucky
doesn't matter whether they are very
common and they upend the story of safe
and effective vaccines or they are very
rare and it's just simply the cost of uh
an improvement in our Collective Health
you have no right to demonize people who
got
hurt yeah I mean obviously I'm biased
when I say that but I would agree agree
with that but I I I would go even
further and just say you don't have to
accept that it was caused by the vaccine
in that case so you don't have to you
don't have to go there yeah just be a
good human being and support somebody
who's going through a rough time right
even even let's agree that a medical
treatment that has a certain number of
adverse reactions that there will also
be people who have the
deep Misfortune of having gotten the
treatment and then having a weird bit of
luck where something completely
unrelated to that treatment befalls them
right in the immediate aftermath and so
they think this happened to them and it
didn't even that person has done nothing
wrong they've extrapolated in a way that
we could all put two things together and
imagine they're connected and they're
not that person also deserves your
compassion you just don't have any right
to demonize any of these people the only
you could demonize somebody who was
lying if somebody was lying to get
attention they are actually hurting
people who've actually been injured that
person does uh deserve ridicule but I I
would just say just quickly on that
point the the lying part unfortunately I
think a lot of
people project
that lying yeah right uh and it's it's
ubiquitous like I I it's it's a it's
crazy like I I I don't think even in my
you know 2020 or pre-2020 mindset I
don't think would have necessarily
jumped to lying at least not in most
cases I would have probably just said
you know you're are mistaken it's
probably with something else like it's
unfortunate that's happening to you but
it probably wasn't the you know super
safe super effective and amazing
vaccines that we all know are
amazing they are amazing at least in a
business sense yeah all right well nick
uh this has been a great discussion I
thought uh we were going to chat for 15
minutes and I think we've gone over an
hour here but anyway uh was a pleasure
thank you for coming up to the islands
and visiting and uh thank you for
courageously exploring a story that it
can't be uh much fun to relive not fun
but uh it was a good exercise and I do
appreciate you making the time thanc
thank you be well everyone thanks
[Music]
everyone